[Music]
e3 2021 it happened and yeah you saw the
big leagues the heavy hitters and all
the other usual suspects
except for sony but unlike previous e3s
giant
aaa games weren't the only ones soaking
up the limelight instead
indies and other hidden gems got their
fair share of stardom standing toe to
toe with some of the loudest titles
on display there's a whole bunch of them
so to make it easy for you
i went through them all and hand-picked
23 hidden gems from e3
2021 to begin
we had the mail carrier 1986 make
friends with townspeople simulator
also known as lake or as i call it my
future retirement plan
[Music]
there is the bullet time frenzy max
payne inspired werewolf vampire shoot em
up in a shape-shifting motel
el paso elsewhere or as i call it
my future retirement plan would you
believe that this is a love story
i would between me and this game
what about that show stopping sci-fi a
retro future 2.5 d
action platformer replaced it's a game
about an artificial intelligence
trapped in a human body against its own
will but
really aren't we all man
that's deep
play as a kid waiting for the end of the
school day to kick a ball around and
most importantly kick it at innocent
bystanders in
despolote additionally learn about life
while you're doing it
man that's really deep
somerville ah nothing like good old
family fun time running for your life
from a civilization on the brink of ruin
but man whoever that guy is he looks
literal
sure nintendo may not be doing anything
with pikmin as far as we know
but hey in the meantime tiny ken has
taken the reins and putting a twist on
it all its
own look at that style
speaking of style what about ditching
computer graphics all together
vocal bulantis is a handcrafted
stop-motion puzzle platformer
and now i demand more hand-crafted video
games
herald halibut is a handmade narrative
game about friendship and life on a
city-sized spaceship stuck on the sea
oh well uh okay sweet harold halibut
is exactly that so thank you
and now for something completely
different like cygnalis
this classic survival horror looks
awesome and terrifying
might need to take a walk and calm down
after playing this one good thing there
was a game called
walk showing off a playstation 1 era
inspired game where you play as a
powerless school girl running from what
the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
okay well maybe signals wasn't that bad
actually
after all enough of the scares
thankfully there was that ghibli
inspired narrative game about being a
painter called behind the frame
also known as my future retirement plan
then there was that one game where the
character puked and then picked it up
and put it right back in his pocket
death trash what a name for cosmic
horror action rpg
and if scoop and puke doesn't seem
interesting at least there's loot river
an action roguelike with spatial block
shifting and
loot and a river
ah death's door we'll all be knocking on
it one day but in the meantime
here's a game where you play as a soul
collecting crow until one of its souls
is stolen and it's up to you to get it
back in this isometric
action game for something less grim
there's toem the game where you take
pictures in a black and white hand-drawn
world and chat with its quirky
inhabitants
and when you're ready to take a break
from your photo taken adventure
kick back to the sizzling sounds of soup
pot and learn how to actually cook real
meals
dude yes oh yes
or how about sable this super sweet
stylized game where you venture through
a sand ridden world discovering ancient
civilizations and technology accompanied
by a soundtrack by japanese breakfast
but maybe you don't like sand
because it's all coarse and rough and
irritating and it gets everywhere
so instead you can explore an ethereal
dreamscape confronting inner nightmares
in this
persona-esque turn-based rpg in she
dreams elsewhere
also we need more immersive sims
thankfully the gloomy steampunk stealth
shooter gloomwood
is coming for me to immerse myself right
into
also that inventory speaking right to my
resident evil 4 heart
i like it and if that one's too dark
you'll be able to wash it down with a
hand painted peaceful platformer
hoa where enemies are instead used to
your advantage to traverse the
environment
citizen sleeper on the other hand takes
the flexibility and fluidity of tabletop
rpgs and launches it right into a space
station
but if that's too slow unbeatable churns
up the tempo in volume in this super
overly stylized rhythm game where music
is illegal which makes doing crimes
totally legit and cool because music is
legit and cool
and with no reasonable transition it'd
be sweet the world we lived in
was actually on the back of a giant
wandering creature which is
exactly what the wandering village is a
city builder sim
on the back of this cutie
so there's a look at 23 hidden gems that
you may have missed during e3 2021. this
year's e3 may not have delivered on all
fronts for a lot of players who've been
eagerly awaiting that next
big look at perfect dark god of war
ragnarok or metroid prime 4.
instead e3 2021 will go down in history
it's giving us a taste of something we
didn't know we wanted and that taste is
something fresh
new and unexpecting let me know if any
of these stood out to you in the
comments below would love to know if one
of these caught your radars that you
otherwise didn't know about
in the meantime i'm just gonna go over
here and watch this trailer on repeat
thanks for coming by and if you'd like
consider giving us a sub
we appreciate it and we talk about video
games a lot which is a thing
i think you like
[Music]
you